à votre intention
nous voulions rencontrer une famille
bien sympathique
le compositeur jean jacques debout
chantal goya sa femme leurs enfants et
leurs chiens
le
le temps de faire connaissance et voilà
les youpi avait disparu ils ont tendance
à s'échapper sans arrêt on est tout le
temps tout le temps visite et l'avait
quand on le garde champêtre qui dirait
maison qui n'arrête pas de contravention
l'attraper parce que ces pauvres chiens
ne sont que courir dans les dents époux
dans les boisés les plaines lesquels
bois des plaines sont remplies d'appâts
empoisonnés alors il t'envoie un peu
affolée mais garde champêtre lui et en
dessus dessous venu dresser des
contraventions
des fois tu as chaud il rentre la nuit
vers 2h30 ou jusqu'à ça peut durer cinq
ans après toute une nuit j'ai dû payer
pour ça alors moi je crevais elle rentre
quand ils ont faim oui quand il pleut
c'était très bien en plus
m
oui qui sait ce chien par rapport au
tien fox et son frère c'est leur frère
effectivement les eaux alors raconte
tout ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui avec
ton et un chien toi ben c'est à dire
qu'ils sont ils sont partis ils sont
partis et puis on les cherche que les
trouve pas ça peut durer combien de
temps jusqu'à ce soir minuit maximum ces
pauvres bêtes là je leur mets délais ce
jeu les enfants et chenil oui j'ai fait
le maximum vous êtes vous oui et puis
alors aujourd'hui on fait on est on est
là et voilà qu'ils sont partis là bon
alors normal sont pointés encore mais
une auto fois parmi plusieurs fois oui
mais où
mais vous voyez nations viennent les
sons aaron de ville sur la ferme de
monsieur m'offrait un à trois kilomètres
de là au point
vous pouvez enregistrer si vous voulez
on a misé à 3km nom des gens qu'est ce
qu'on en fait il bon ils sont sur la
plaine ou près des voies ont pu aller
ensemble
il bat toute la la plainte de monsieur
geoffrey et adhérents la fédération qui
paient une cotisation il faut envolés
les couples de deux perdreaux et alors
qu'on connaissait alors contenu
chasseurs viennent tuer toutes ces bêtes
là vous croyez pas que c'est moi d'y
installer en tout cas pas vous mais d'y
aller au delà des lois légalement la
divagation des chiens issus pas les
bêtes
vous devriez connaître la loi vous
montez à la natation siens en période de
fermeture est interdite
enfin coup de partage
ces bons vieux navires par esprit
et
verte ailleurs
chen zhu royal femme
je
m
ma
ans
trente deux chiennes qui sont nés à 12
je crois dont la mère est un basset
artésien et le pen est un braque
c'est une race très très rare il y en a
un en angleterre et ça s'appelle débat
c'est bleu ils ont à peu près huit mois
un livre à lui moins huit mois et demi
et vous y avez vu à quel âge de moi
demain
c'est un label qui nous les affaires
très gentiment premièrement ils sont
sont têtus ils sont désobéissants du
coup on n'écoute jamais et en plus de ça
ils vont avec tout le monde
jean-paul alors comment s'appelle si
celui-là youpi comme l'autre pas comme
l'autre
oui parce qu'on les a appelés les de
youppi parce que cela ne suffisait pas
si on appelait quart seulement y avait
qu'une qui revenait quand il fallait que
les deux os vient on les appelait tous
les deuils ou pis alors d'habitude des
enfants sont jaloux des chiens d'une
famille mais là j'ai l'impression que
c'est pas tout à fait le cas
ah non ça fait partie de la famille les
chiens les chiens c'est s'est séparé
aucune jalousie entre les humains et les
chiens
absolument pas clarisse est ce que tu
sais l'âge de tes chiens
oui c'est moi et moi j'aimerais savoir
comment tu le reconnais parce que c'est
là la grande reine blanche et puis celle
elle emmène toute petite tu veux du
aussi klein que chen moment où l'autre
de x factor et lasserre semblablement
parce qu'elle a une tête toute fine et
poussaient leur savoir-faire pas
pourquoi ce qu'est boudent toujours
chantal pour vous qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est ce que ça représente avoir un
chien dans une maison à voir deux chiens
dans une maison ça représente quoi
c'est d'une compagnie oui moi pour moi
c'est une compagnie parce que souvent
quand je suis seul et je leur parle à
ses chiens
je raconte des histoires je raconte ce
que j'ai fait dans ma journée je raconte
je leur dis venez vous promener au nom
va peut se promener dedans et vous
sauver alors ils me regardent avec des
têtes comme ça ils font plein de munich
grand la tournée tête en sang menées
elles sont très comics des chiens
comiques quand même elles ont des
grosses pattes pato elles sont on peut
les toucher les bouger les embrasser les
tourner dans tous les sens elles fondre
sont ravis
c'est parti de la maison c'est obligé
qui déchaîne dans une maison je vois pas
une maison son chien ne vois pas une
famille sans enfant
à
on
même